turning to justin bieber now you know he
was supposed to be on tour
right now but of course the pandemic
changed all of that but
he really is enjoying this time
especially with his wife hayley
our exclusive with the biebers is up
first in tonight's know and
only tell well we didn't make any babies
so that's that we're still pretty newly
married i mean
we'll be celebrating two years in
september
we've just been enjoying our time with
each other and getting to know each
other deeper
we've been road tripping which i guess
is the best way to like
stay in social distance social distance
yeah it's just the two of us
the bieber's other summer activities
they got baptized together
for just in their shirtless golf and the
couple also joined the first ever
virtual paley fest la
streaming on youtube we have an
exclusive look at why the biebs thinks
his recent confessions about anxiety and
depression
were a good thing as someone who has
such a large
platform i feel like it's my honor to
be able to show those weak those those
vulnerable sides to say
if justin with all this these things and
you know money and fame and all this
stuff still struggles with his mental
health and i'm not alone
from one famous duo to another cameron
diaz joined longtime friend gwyneth
paltrow
on her digital series in goop health the
sessions
cameron opened up about why she walked
away from hollywood
i decided to stop making movies
um and really focus on my
my personal life my personal
relationships what did it feel like
to walk away from a movie career
of that magnitude a piece i got a piece
in my soul
because i finally was taking care of
myself
and raising seven month old daughter
radix when people are like she's so cute
or she's so pretty i don't want her to
identify
with those adjectives all i want to do
is help her be her
and then there's how she finally found
true love with benji madden
gwyneth joked about some of cameron's
famous exes including
justin timberlake a-rod matt dillon and
jared leto
i was afraid i wouldn't you know find a
partner
i had no luck you know i didn't have
people that i
in my life yeah you had some real
humdingers in there
as for gwyneth she tells british vogue
how she felt about the famous phrase
conscious uncoupling it was introduced
to her and her first husband chris
martin by their therapist
she admits frankly the term sounded a
bit full of itself
painfully progressive and hard to
swallow i was intrigued
less by the praise but by the sentiment